[Music]
so
good morning everybody it is seven
o'clock the widow who's won a change in
the law so people who kill emergency
service workers will soon face mandatory
live terms in memory of pc andrew harper
we'll speak to the deputy prime minister
and justice secretary dominic raab this
morning about that plus a warning that
the rate of vaccinating children against
covet in the uk is just too slow we'll
talk to two top scientists about that
including the world health organization
plus the shadow education secretary kate
green
also this morning for you're going to be
joined by former professional rugby
league player alex popham to discuss why
retired players are more likely to
suffer poor mental health in later life
compared to non-contact athletes and
[Music]
oh yes they are a christmas panto with
the pritchards we'll speak to our
favorite prince charming aj and curtis
about their family pantomime cinderella
spectacular that's a quarter to ten it's
wednesday the 24th of november harper's
law mandatory live terms for those who
kill emergency service workers under a
new law triggered by the death of pc
andrew harper
and i'm here at the minister of justice
where the government says it's on the
side of victims but what will this mean
in practice
vaccine target an accusation from labor
that some 12 to 15 year olds won't be
vaccinated until february nearly four
months behind target
a beautiful sister a brother's tribute
as two men arrested on suspicion of
murdering a teenager who went missing in
plymouth
an eight-year-old boy is the sixth
person to die after a vehicle drove into
a christmas parade in wisconsin as the
suspect appears in court
three
two
one
and
liftoff
throwing targets into space nasa's new
rocket lifts off on a test mission to
try to alter the course of an asteroid
i'm live in the ethiopian capital as the
us warns that peace talks here are
faltering
that as rebel fighters draw closer to
this city addis ababa from the north
[Music]
good morning everybody a law change in
memory of a police officer who lost his
life in the line of duty people who kill
emergency service workers will face
mandatory life terms after the
government backed the move following the
death of pc andrew harper something his
widow has been campaigning for they plan
to introduce harper's law as soon as
possible
let's get the latest on that now from
melania who's standing by for us at the
ministry of justice hello to elena very
good morning tell us more about this
good morning kay well you might remember
pc harper died in august 2019 he was
responding to calls of a quad bike being
stolen and in the course of responding
to that call as he was getting after the
getaway car he got entangled in a robe
that was
towing this quad bike and then he was
dragged along the road for more than a
mile suffering catastrophic injuries and
tragically dying now his teenage killers
were convicted of manslaughter so they
were not given this this mandatory life
tariff that normally comes with a murder
charge and since then really his family
and his widow lissy have been
campaigning tirelessly to change this
law and now with a change in law anyone
who kills an emergency worker be a
paramedic or a police officer in the
course of committing a crime
will get this mandatory life sentence
now it's worth also noting this has sat
slightly uneasily with some lawyers who
say that you're now blurring that
difference between manslaughter which
means you've killed someone without
intent and murder which means you've
gone out with an intention to actually
end someone's life but nonetheless this
is a victory if you can call it that way
for the family of pc andrew harper in
the wake of what was really a tragic
event in their lives okay melania thank
you
and at a quarter to nine this morning
going to be putting questions on
harper's law uh this morning's other top
stories as well to the justice secretary
and deputy prime minister dominic raab
to coronavirus now and there's a warning
that the rate of vaccinating children
against covid in the uk is just
too slow it comes as the government
suggests new advice that you should take
lateral flow tests before seeing elderly
relatives and going into crowded places
some look at some of the main covid
talking points for you this morning here
we go comes as analysis from labor shows
that some 12 to 15 year olds may not be
vaccinated until february that's 15
weeks after the original october
half-term target
meanwhile the government has advised the
public to take a lateral flow test
before spending time in crowded and
enclosed spaces this winter obviously
shopping and the lead scientist on the
covid study that's uh professor tim
spector last night told sky news that
kovid
looks like they may stay flat in the
run-up to the figures may stay flat in
the run-up to christmas but could get
worse again in the new year
rob butler executive director of the
world health organization is uh joining
us now from uh in europe in fact uh
joining us now as you can see very good
morning to you thank you so much for
joining us on the programme this morning
what's your overall take on what's
happening with covid as of today
thanks kay um good morning we're very
alarmed um we have uh just passed just
surpassed very sadly the 1.5 million
death mark last week
if we continue on the current course
we are projecting a further five over
half a million five hundred thousand
deaths by spring
next year that's really worrisome of
course public health cost
the cost to our economies the stress on
our hospitals and communities uh and our
icus of course our intensive care units
so we're very concerned we in the
european region the 53 member states
that who regional office here in
copenhagen serve only 54
of the population of this region are
vaccinated so there's so much work to be
done still um we're not there yet and it
looks like we're going to have a
worrisome
season ahead
what's driving the um resurgence of
kovids in mainland europe is it the fact
is it the lack of vaccines or is it as
the guy who um
is the chief executive astrazeneca has
said the vaccines in the uk on the
elderly worked the az vaccine worked
much more effectively
well it's partly due to there being too
many vulnerable populations to infection
of vaccination um also we're seeing
waning immunity of these vaccines
especially around after the 30-week mark
of the full course
also we've got as i say 45 47 of the
entire population unvaccinated
um and the unvaccinated let me
absolutely clear the majority of people
in ic in intensive care units and icus
today are the unvaccinated but there are
other compounding factors okay
winter
this is a seasonality uh observation
we're making at the moment
people moving indoors
need for masks a need for more
ventilation masks as you possibly saw um
from the british medical journal the bmj
this last week showed a study where 53
percent of transmission
was prevented by mask use we only have
48 of the population in the european
region using masks the moment we saw
that go up if we see this go up we will
have see see a reduction in cases and a
reduction in deaths if we saw 95
universal
mass use
we could project that we would save
about 160 000 lives so this is a number
of factors plus the more transmissible
delta variant which is accounting for
about 99 of the cases in europe today
that's why this is happening
so wearing a mask would save 160 000
lives in europe or worldwide
europe um if we saw 95 percent mass
queues we'd see over 160 000 lives saved
from the projection that you you stated
earlier
okay and just if i could take you back
to the astrazeneca line that we um are
in a lot of the newspapers this morning
pascal sorry suggesting that his
vaccination the astrazeneca jab um being
used on older people uh more here in the
uk than in europe that is the reason
that europe is doing not as well as the
uk is
well i wouldn't start comparing
different vaccines i mean all vaccines
have been used in elderly populations
there are varying vaccination coverage
rates across europe
and that's why we're seeing this delta
variant this highly transmissible delta
variant find out these pockets of
vulnerability and susceptible
populations i don't think it's useful
that we go into which vaccine has done
better where
what we need is every member of society
vaccinated and of course those that are
particularly vulnerable the elderly um
the healthcare worker of course
healthcare workers are front line uh
those that are immunocompromised uh that
they take a booster when they're offered
one um this is this is also very
important and will make a big difference
um should we be traveling at the moment
traveling but traveling safely um i i'd
like to think we're gonna have a merry
christmas but a safe christmas so i i
think um we all hope as to my own
children hope that christmas is on um we
believe it is um that people will be
able to uh travel we hope that they will
be able to travel but i think a bigger
question is uh how they behave when they
travel so again mascus physical
distancing hand washing
and
adherence to those public health social
measures will be so much more important
over this coming season
but we don't need to worry about um
traveling around europe at the moment
given the numbers that we're seeing in
belgium and germany and austria and the
like and then obviously the traveling
from the united kingdom to europe the
who still feels that that's acceptable
yeah we think that the travel travel
route should be kept open at this point
um but the care should be taken and of
course um vaccine passports used where
where they're being used where they're
um uh i'm southern copenhagen um where i
cannot enter buildings without my um my
green pass um
these these these passes if you like are
actually providing us
giving us enabling us
um to um avoid lockdowns and remain um
able to move um so that's a very good
thing um that uh they're used and
applied in in many member states today
um you must be frustrated to read that
the british government has destroyed
something like 600 000 vaccine doses
because they're out of date when they
could have been
shipped to
countries that need them
indeed i mean uh what i think
we keep we keep explaining to our member
states and and try and communicate as
clearly as possible is
that um we need to keep an eye on
supplies we need to make sure that there
is equitable distribution of these
vaccines and that
if countries plan to for example start
booster campaigns etc
that they are confident that they will
be able to use the vaccines um that they
that they order that they they are
provided because of course there is only
a finite supply
and what happens and your thoughts on
throwing them away
well it's never good to see a vaccine
thrown away of course but uh this can't
be avoided if you don't have the demand
for the vaccines or your system doesn't
allow you to present those vaccines
administer those vaccines then of course
they they have to be thrown away if
they're if they're out of date if they
expire
but presumably we could be in a position
via kovacs um where we can transport
those vaccines you know if they've got
the sell by date on them use by date on
them we can put them on an airplane and
send them to africa that's what we're
promoting i mean where we can let's see
that vaccine solidarity um across europe
and across the world indeed couldn't i
couldn't agree more
and as far as the sale sell-by dates on
these vaccines are concerned we were
speaking to our resident gp about that a
little while ago and he was saying
it's different obviously we can't use
them after the um
used by date but how do we know that
they're no longer usable by that day
because they're a new vaccine we don't
know how long they're going to last do
you have a view on that
i don't really i mean a good
manufacturing and pre-qualification that
who conducts on all of our vaccines
basically suggests an expiry date as to
the manufacturers of course
and we adhere to that um these are new
vaccines so still a lot of as you've
just alluded to a lot of uh studies
still ongoing
a lot of science still to be found
around the vaccines and their longevity
um of course we're all we're all hoping
that we can see vaccines lasting longer
and and of course the um
the uh the waning immunity that we're
seeing at the moment we need to tackle
that um because
we need uh of course not to see that in
the future we need those vaccines to be
to be powerful enough to protect us all
in the long term
okay quick thought before i let you go
where are you on compulsory vaccines
um mandates
mandates compulsory vaccine it's a
healthy debate right now i mean
mandatory vaccination can
but doesn't always
increase uptake there are lessons of
history here um where mandates have come
at an expense of
trust and social inclusion so it's very
delicate but we believe it's time for to
have that conversation um both from an
individual and also a popular
population-based perspective um it's a
healthy debate to have
okay uh it's good to talk to you thank
you very much indeed for joining us on
the programme this morning thank you mr
mottle from the world health
organization thanks a lot
thanks
quick look at the latest covert data for
you that we have this morning uh 42
484 new cases of the virus have been
recorded 165 more people
have died the total
of people who have died in the uk
144
137
23 258 people received their first dose
of a vaccine in the last day the number
of people receiving their second dose um
just over 18 and a half thousand uh
46.19 million people have now had both
of their vaccines and what about the
boosters
while the government did say they would
be up at half a million a day didn't
they and that dropped to 308
000
yesterday uh giving in the last 24 hours
taking the total number of those doses
to 15.
million people who've had their booster
still to come on the program for you
going to be speaking to the shadow
education secretary about new analysis
from the labour party which projects
that some 12 to 15 year olds will not be
vaccinated until at least february
joined by former professional rugby
player alex popham
to discuss why retired players are more
likely to suffer poor mental health in
later life compared to non-contact
athletes
and we'll meet the 12 year old boy who's
raised hundreds of thousands of pounds
for his local hospice by sleeping out in
a tent for more than 600 days
two men aged 24 and 26 from plymouth
have been arrested on suspicion of
murder after a body has been found by
police investigating the disappearance
of an 18 year old girl
bobby ann mccloud was reported missing
on saturday after she failed to meet
friends in the city writing on social
media her brother lee said i love you
you didn't deserve this
his facebook post says such a beautiful
and talented girl and to have you as my
little sister the adventure and journey
we had been on will always be treasured
now go rest easy
last night the uh plymouth police
superintendent gave an update on the
case
this is wayne heavy on the people of
plymouth tonight it really is
last line and i would like to just send
my thoughts to the friends and family of
bobby anne we are doing our utmost and
will continue to do everything we can to
understand exactly what's happened
around this event when i've got any more
details that i can share with you we
will do that
oh this is terrible story an
eight-year-old boy sixth person to have
died after a car sped into a christmas
parade in the u.s state of wisconsin
remember we're telling you about that a
couple of days ago jackson sparks
here he is he died in hospital last
night having attended the parade with
his 12 year old brother who was also
injured more than 60 other people hurt
several remain critically ill in
hospital rest in peace little man
the suspect here is daryl brooks
appeared in court yesterday for the
first time charged with five counts of
intentional homicide it comes after the
courthood he had previously been charged
with running over the mother of his
child in a domestic dispute nbc reporter
jay gray has the latest
an eight-year-old who was injured during
the tragedy here along with his
12-year-old brother his brother doing
well in fact dismissed from the hospital
today but the eight-year-old succumbed
to his injuries and died today
during the sentencing hearing here or
the announcing of sentences
of charges rather against the suspect in
this case
he faces five counts of homicide as you
talked about likely to get a sixth added
after this news today he was in shackles
and had a mask over his face
he's familiar with the legal system here
and and really across the country has an
extensive background of violent crimes
including in 2020 firing shots at his
nephew after they were in an argument
and then earlier this month he is
accused of punching the mother of his
child and then using the same suv that
he used
during what many here call an attack at
that parade to run over her legs so it's
something that he had done before
there's a bit of back and forth the d.a
here
saying that he is very concerned that
such a low bail was uh granted for him
to be released from
that arrest after he ran over
the mother of his child a thousand
dollars was all that was required to get
him out of jail he left on a friday and
a tragedy took place on that saturday so
a lot of people looking into that
let's take a look at some of the other
stories making news for you this morning
on the program the home office should be
stripped of all responsibility for the
windrush compensation scheme according
to a committee of mps the commons home
affairs committee says it's discovered
what it calls a litany of flaws in the
way the system works less than 30
percent of people who've applied for
compensation have actually received
anything
and it's that around five percent of
those who are most likely eligible for
compensation have received anything
we've had the awful tragedy of 23 people
having died before they got the
compensation that they were entitled to
that's why we need urgent reforms to the
system we need to recognize what a
terrible scandal the windrush scandal
was and the obligation on the government
to put this right
a landmark case in the u.s has found
that three chain pharmacies recklessly
distributed massive amounts of pain
pills in two ohio counties
lake and trumbull counties blamed cvs
walgreens and walmart for not stopping
the flood of pills that caused hundreds
of overdose deaths
how much the pharmacist must pay in
damages will be decided in the spring by
a federal judge
this is a landmark decision because it's
the first time
that the issues of opioid epidemic have
been tried against
these national chain pharmacies
a rape conviction at the center of an
award-winning memoir by alice siebold
has been overturned amid concerns the
wrong person was sent to jail in 1982.
anthony broadwater who spent 16 years in
prison was cleared of raping seabolt
when she was a student concerns came
after a producer who was making the
memoir into a film began questioning why
the first draft of the script differed
from the original writing
the man convicted of the murder of the
british student meredith kircher has
been freed from jail rudy aguedy was
released after serving most of his
16-year term
21 year old student meredith was
murdered in italy in october of 2007
sir rod stewart has called for the
introduction of menopause classes for
men quite right too just a warning
there's some flash photography coming up
76 year old singer is calling for the
classes after watching his wife penny
lancaster battle with severe symptoms
sarod said classes would be a very good
way to go to help husbands and partners
better understand common symptoms
investigation by sky news has uncovered
allegations that a gang of child abusers
is allegedly at large in hull police
there have been urged to declare war on
a child's grooming gang after several
women said they were abused by a group
of men operating in the city an
investigation into the alleged crimes
has gone dormant but the uk's former top
child abuse investigator has called for
detectives to double down on the case
after examining a thousand pages of
evidence
it's not just he said she said we've got
a number of victor victims saying here's
the pattern of behavior it's identical
and this is the person that does it is
your gut feeling that this this case
should be tested in court
oh absolutely
i mean
if they need additional evidence
then go out and get it we're almost at
the point where we need to declare war
on this type of behavior we need to say
it is a priority
and you can see more of that special
report from our home affairs editor
jason farrell in hull throughout the day
here on sky news you can check it out
online as well and we will be speaking
to jason in the nine o'clock hour here
on sky
in the last hour nasa has launched a
test rocket on a mission to protect
earth from asteroids
the dart is flying to demorphus which is
a small asteroid moonlet apparently the
target is not a threat to earth and it
is in orbit around a larger asteroid
known as didimos
nasa says this system is a perfect
testing ground for the dart i'll be
taking notes at the back in september
next year dart will crash into the
smaller rock at 15 000 miles an hour
that's around four miles a second
the impact will change the speed of the
asteroid by a fraction of a millimeter
per second changing its orbit which will
be closely monitored by scientists
three
two
one
and
liftoff of the falcon 9 and dark
this is the moment when darts set off on
its journey to the asteroid
our science correspondent thomas more is
uh is with us now hello to you thomas
good morning this is pretty cool
yeah look i mean hollywood has it has
had a go hasn't it with armageddon and
deep impact now now it's nasa's turn and
they're doing it for real but instead of
a nuclear bomb they're using spacecraft
which is it's about the size of one of
those big washing machines you get
inside a lawn direct weighs half a ton
and they're going to smash it into this
spacecraft a space rock which is much
bigger it's 160
meters across but i hope that high
impact speed 15 000 miles an hour is
going to be enough to nudge it slightly
off course now as you say this
particular asteroid dimorphos is not a
risk to us but there are probably lots
of others out there that could impact
the earth at some point in the future
and let's face it has in the past just
asked the dinosaurs
but it's thought that if you can nudge
it off with a bit of time you might be
able to divert it enough so it goes
round the earth and
we we all live to fight another day
but it is something that nasa is taking
very seriously as it's learning more
about the number of rocks out there it
needs to find some way of of just making
sure that we all stay safe
okay thanks thomas thanks a lot
fascinating stuff here amazing
looking at some of the other stories
making the papers this morning here we
go harper's law a mandatory life
sentence for those who kill a police
officer or a 999 worker is the front
page of the daily mail this morning
comes after a campaign
by lizzie harper the widow of pc andrew
harper who was killed responding to a
burglar do you remember that story
blessa
so she's going to meet the deputy
prime minister later on today to talk
about it in more detail and we will also
be speaking to dominic rob in the next
hour also the express shows this photo
of the manchester arena bomber salman
abadi
holding a mammoth machine gun the paper
says it was taken in 2011 in libya
twins killed as 46 perish in the holiday
bus inferno we talked about that
yesterday didn't we those are the
picture of those two little boys that's
lewin and album
just four years old twins
and they were on that bus that crashed
and burst into flames in the early hours
of the morning in western bulgaria
planets align this stunning image shows
jupiter saturn and venus above
stonehenge in wiltshire
and it has gone absolutely viral it was
captured by members of stonehenge
dronescapes who took ten eight-second
exposures and merge them to reveal
greater detail than can be seen by the
naked eye now i don't know which ones
those are but you probably do is it
saturn that's always the brightest
and mercury's there as well i'm guessing
don't know i'll find out mercury's in
the middle apparently i think that's
saturn there isn't it and that one's
another planet um now
check i love this
that's a bit woof isn't it
how did he get up there the owner of
this dog
looked everywhere for him couldn't find
him carl barrett's couldn't find the dog
he's only a puppy looking at the size of
me apparently he's still on your puppy
looked everywhere around his mom's house
in cheshire went outside had a look
around the garden nothing where was he
literally on the roof how did they get
there they have no idea but thankfully
the nine stone said bernard turned up
and there he is um i have no idea how he
got there it's great story isn't it
fantastic his name samson of course it
is now how's this for a statement a 10
meter floating earth created by
international artist luke jerram has
been unveiled at a beauty spot
in wigan visitors catch it at pennington
flash nature reserve until
sunday there you go it looks very much
like cop26 doesn't it the earth that we
saw there i don't think it is but it's
um just look how beautiful it is and we
can told you god's own country and now
quick look at the climate dashboard
trying to protect that of course you can
see the estimated temperature change
compared to pre-industrial levels this
is now above
1.2 degrees under that is the estimated
total carbon dioxide emissions most of
this comes from burning fossil fuels and
continues to rise and then you can see
on the right hand side should we see the
real time actually no it's at the top
isn't it today the real-time power mix
that's from the national grid 47
gas we are using today using quite a lot
of coal as well actually as it gets
colder 4.4 of coal when we were up at
cop26 that was down to zero keeping an
eye on those numbers for you
a new stay indoors warning has been
introduced in la palma after the spanish
island was hit by fresh lava flows from
an exploding volcano been keeping an eye
on that as well haven't we residents in
three towns have been told to stay
indoors with officials warning of toxic
gases spreading across the island you'll
know by now that happens when the lava
reaches the sea and then it creates that
that toxic toxic gas cloud people living
in the capital santa cruz have been
ordered to wear face masks for the first
time because of high levels of sulfur
dioxide people living
in the capital as i said told to wear
those
face masks
quick look at the weather for you now
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
uh colder this week is what we're being
told uh some wintry hazards and very
strong winds likely especially on friday
and saturday mostly dry out there now
but the north has some rain and mountain
snow is chilly with patches of frost and
fog in the south mainly the south east
oh look at those temperatures
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
why do you think the happiest place to
live in britain is
well apparently it's hexam in
northumberland according to an annual
poll the 800 year old market town is
said to have contented population um
harrogate richmond and sterling were
among the top 10 happy at home index
that's lovely isn't it how beautiful is
that there you go cold outside but we've
got lovely pictures for you
gorgeous hexam in northumberland
now
could we see any more coveted
restrictions if cases rise throughout
the winter coming up we're going to be
speaking to a member of sage
stay tuned for more
[Music]
world health organization has called for
more mask wearing to keep covid cases
down earlier on the programme the
executive director of the wh sho in
europe rob butler told me that more than
150
000 lives could be saved in europe if
more people wore face coverings
if we saw 95 universal
mask use
we could project that we would save
about 160 000 lives so there's a number
of factors plus the more transmissible
delta variant which is accounting for
about 99 of the cases in europe today
that's why this is happening we're very
alarmed um we have uh just passed just
surpassed very sadly the 1.5 million
death mark uh last week
if we continue on the current course
we are projecting a further five over
half a million 500 000
deaths by spring next year mandates
mandates compulsory vaccine it's a
healthy debate right now i mean
mandatory vaccination can
but doesn't always
um increase uptake there are lessons of
history here um where mandates have come
at an expense of
trust and social inclusion so it's very
delicate but we believe it's time for to
have that conversation
both from an individual and also a
popular population-based perspective
it's a healthy debate to have
well professor thomas who's from the
institute of immunology and
immunotherapy at the university of
birmingham joining us now hello to you
thank you for joining us on the
programme mandatory vaccines thoughts on
that one to start with
well we've seen in europe this week
haven't we the challenge that that can
impose and we just heard from the
colleague there about issues about trust
and so forth so i think we're quite away
from that in the uk we're starting to
see it brought into particular workers
of course um in in care services and
health workers so perhaps that's the
approach that the uk will take
i mean i think what the whole i mean i i
didn't expect the world health
organization to say that it that it's um
a conversation that now needs to be had
that obviously reflecting on the fact
that almost half of people in europe
have not taken the vaccine taken up the
opportunity to have the vaccine yet
that's absolutely right you're up around
46 vaccinating i think as you say what
we're seeing week after week is the
power of these vaccines and how
incredibly effective they are
particularly with this booster vaccine
the third vaccine i think we we perhaps
felt that might top up our immunity but
it takes it to another level of
protection 93
protection against infection so because
the vaccines are so incredibly effective
that's why this debate is very very
active at the current time particularly
given this new wave
interestingly um the professor the
doctor from the world health
organization rob butler also said to me
that
if we wore masks if they were mandatory
then um we'd save 160 000 lives in
europe
really interesting paper last week in
the british medical journal showing that
mask wearing does reduce transmission by
around 50 percent so there's strong
evidence that it does work um around 48
percent of people in europe do wear a
mask and as you can see if you increase
that that's where he projects those
lives saved
and what's your thoughts on the comments
from the chief exec of astrazeneca
saying that um his vaccination is better
than others especially with old people
and as a result that's why europe who
didn't use it as much as the uk is not
faring as well
i thought those very interesting
comments on my own group works very much
on that area i think uk has some
different vaccine policies we were the
first of course we started in december
last year and therefore we saw the
waning early and we've exited this
summer our policy was to to create a
longer term immunity during the summer
and i think that's given us the benefit
we had some other slightly different
things about our vaccination we extended
the interval between from 3 to 10 to 12
weeks and that's going to give us it
seems perhaps stronger immunity as for
the az vaccine yes our own work has
shown it gives very strong cellular
immunity and perhaps in the long term
that could be beneficial but as pascal
suarez said himself we don't quite have
that evidence yet
if that's the case why are the boosters
pfizer and not azad
interesting question i mean i think um
the mrna vaccines do give stronger
antibody immunity and that's really what
people have depended on this summer um
and so i i don't honestly know why
certainly az can be given but the
availability of the mrna was just
slightly better for boosters the
combination by the way of a z and an
mrna is itself very powerful and could
be something considered in the future
and
we don't know at this stage how long is
a piece of string but is it looking more
and more likely that we will need to
have boosters every year
that's a credible
interesting question um i've just said
that the third booster is great but then
the question is how long is that going
to last for do we need another one six
months we just don't know i hope not
that we will reach some plateau
certainly against protection against
severe disease death hospitalization
that should be quite long-lasting
yeah boosting people every six months is
going to be a logistical nightmare
though isn't it especially as we're
hearing that kids some kids are not even
going to get their first vaccination
until february
yeah be unfortunate if we have to go
that way and as i say although you might
want to do that to get lovely antibody
levels in the laboratory i think in
terms of protection we will see that to
be much more long-lasting
and thoughts on on kids
waiting such a long time to have their
vaccinations and indeed vaccinating them
in the first place
i think we had that debate didn't we a
few weeks ago it was always delicately
poised and i think it was it was done
because
the consideration was given with
children in mind what was the best thing
for them we know that they have low risk
of severe disease from the infection and
so to vaccinate them to protect the
adults it's always a moral question i
think we've got the balance about right
in the uk and i think uk vaccine policy
actually has been very sound on the
israelis though i think of am i writing
saying that in israel that
five-year-olds are now about to be
vaccinated or certainly they've been
given the authority to be able to
vaccinate um five-year-olds are we going
to go down to that age level
again we're seeing uh the the age limit
coming down as we see more about learn
more about the safety of the vaccines in
children so we may well get to that area
israel is a very interesting case as you
mentioned they were about the first
country to get very strong vaccine
coverage across the whole country
after the vaccination there was a second
wave and then after the boosters they're
now under complete very good control
again so they're a model for what we can
achieve
okay um professor good to talk to you as
always thanks for your expertise much
appreciated thank you very much
um tamar is with us good morning
tomorrow interesting that the world
health organization suggesting um
that you know we should have the
discussion about compulsory vaccinations
that's right i mean areas where we
thought we would never go are now under
discussion clearly now obviously he was
talking about all of europe and in terms
of vaccination rate the uk very much
leads the league tables in europe there
are countries in eastern europe where
vaccination rates are a lot lower in
austria where they've gone down this
road of compulsory vaccination for
everybody the vaccination rate is only
about 66 which is one of the reasons
they've had this big surge so i think
there's a lot to be said for the good
place that the uk is in according to all
the scientists that's the message you
heard from paul moss there at birmingham
university but after the government has
already brought in that measure for care
home staff and are bringing it in for
nhs staff they say
yes the question is about where it goes
and of course what might be the civil
liberties implications the message
firmly from the government is they don't
want to go any further than we have done
at the moment but of course things do
change we never would have thought that
nhs staff would have to be have
compulsory vaccinations probably just a
few months ago and mask wearing
apparently if we wear masks more more of
us wear masks around europe will save
160 000 lives um on the continent and
the uk and yet you know we see our prime
minister not wearing his
that's right so that figure comes from
the british medical journal uh research
which found that uh masks are the single
most effective public health measure and
if you increase mask wearing this is
across europe from about half to about
95 percent then uh in theory that could
save 160 000 lives um out of the half a
million that they think
half a million people who it's projected
will die between now and spring next
year he said it's alarming how many
people are going to die of cobit across
europe over the next few months of lives
could be saved and if you wear a mask
that that seemed to be what he was
saying and he said it so you know so
obviously it's a hugely important
measure um
desert in the uk it is mandatory in some
parts of the uk but not in england and
of course there is lots of debate about
other measures like ventilation as well
but that is interesting research which
showed that mask wearing is really the
key
weird when we went up to cop26 a couple
of weeks ago we were on the train from
houston to glasgow as you go across the
border there's not on the train to put
your mask on yes and mask wearing is um
that is very strong in in scotland there
are lots of pictures of people out and
about the government's guidance
interestingly changed yesterday on
testing saying that
up to now has been that you have to test
twice a week now they're suggesting that
you might want to do a lateral flow test
every time you go into a crowded space
like christmas shopping wow goodness and
how long will they be free for another
question to ask later on for now thanks
very much tomorrow's takes at nine
o'clock looking forward to it already
meantime the us has warned peace
negotiators in ethiopia risk being
outpaced by an alarming military
escalation it follows ethiopia's prime
minister posting on social media that he
will personally go to the front line to
face armed rebels who are getting closer
to the capital addis ababa goodness me
um our africa correspondent john sparks
with us now hi john goodness to me
that's um that's quite a is it a threat
or is it a promise i'm not sure
uh good question i think people are are
still struggling to understand the
implications of all this it gets quite
unsettled here in
addis ababa it is one of africa's great
uh cities and i think it's sort of
plagued with uncertainty now people here
were aware of the tplf rebel advance the
tplf from the region of tigre people
knew that they were getting closer to
the capital but the fact that abby ahmed
the prime minister has gone to the front
to lead the army i think has made it
real it's made it more threatening um
made it much more urgent and on top of
that you've got foreign nationals from
countries like france canada even
neighboring sudan their governments
telling their citizens to get out of
ethiopia so it has made the situation
very real i mean as for abby ahmed we've
seen or heard nothing official
from him or of him at the front and i
was just speaking to his spokesperson a
few minutes ago she had nothing to add
on this matter but i think one of the
worries will be that the fact that he's
decided to do this will inspire a whole
lot of other ordinary so-called ordinary
people in ethiopia to go and join him at
the front without equipment without
training and that raises the worry about
potentially huge loss of life we do have
international peace envoys like jeffrey
feltman from the u.s
shuttling between the various capitals
yesterday he said he thought he was
making progress but that progress being
rapidly outpaced by alarming military
development developments he said i think
the problem here is that both sides see
a military solution to this both sides
seek the elimination militarily of each
other at the moment and there's no
impetus to sit down and talk
okay well now thanks a lot john thanks
for explaining that to us
uh could there be a link between contact
sports and uh poor mental health we'll
talk to a former professional rugby
player shortly
[Music]
a new study suggests retired
professional rugby players are more
likely to feel depression and anxiety
compared to non-contact athletes
researchers from durham university
suggest there's a link between the
amount of concussions suffered on the
pitch and worse mental health in later
life
former professional rugby player alex
popham with us now hello to alex thanks
for joining us what do you make of this
research ah good morning thanks for
having me um it doesn't surprise me one
bit um i've been speaking to
uh to players over the last 18 months
now who who are in a really bad way and
on some instances i've got to get
medical uh interventions and get them to
speak to professionals because yeah
unfortunately they're they've been
suicidal
uh tell me about your experience alex
um it's well i've been trying to support
help uh quite a few few players and
give them the advice after my diagnosis
of what's been working for me
my diet my exercise get into a into a
good routine but that doesn't work for
anybody uh for everybody um and that's
where uh we've had to get
pre-professional uh help for them um
so yeah that's the the situation
we're in and as i said it doesn't
surprise me one bit
okay but um as far as i mean tell us
about your experience when you were
playing and the impact that it's had on
you
subsequently
well um
whilst i was playing it it was just part
of the game we weren't educated on what
concussion was
i've learned a hell of a lot over the
last 18 months since my diagnosis i
always thought a concussion was where
you were knocked out cold i've now uh i
now know that 90 of concussions are
where you're not knocked out so when i
was seeing stars almost every other day
that's that's the concussion and this is
where it's so important and we've had
for change the foundation we've we've
set up it's about educating people from
grassroots all the way up uh until uh
elite level and um to get the message
out that this is important and and
players need to take it seriously
um
you i think i'm saying that you've been
diagnosed
with early onset dementia alex how did
it feel
to realize that that was a direct result
of playing a sport that you loved
it it was a hard one because it was in
the middle of lockdown and we had the
consultation over over zoom and it gave
us some answers to why uh certain things
were happening what i was what i was
struggling with
um but
i just wish uh because the the evidence
was there whilst i was playing i just
wish we were told
about concussions because it was taken
as a as a bit of a joke if you had bambi
legs and you were all over the place it
was get up you're not dead get back into
your defensive line and things have got
better but there's still a lot more that
can be done to protect these guys and
women unfortunately women are struggling
too
yeah um look after yourself alex thanks
for taking the time to join us good luck
and um enjoy the family thank you very
much cheers bye-bye
thanks a lot alex
coming up the executive director of the
world health organization in europe has
told sky news more than 160 000 lives
could be saved on the continent if more
people were face max masks i should say
he also went on to say that mandatory
vaccinations
are a conversation that now needs to be
had
but you've got a strong view on that
haven't you you can tweet me directly if
you would like to at k burley talking
about it in more detail in just a few
moments here on sky
[Music]